it's good to be here it's hard to be
Asian and not have people call you a
mentor every know them know this country
of Chinese from a Province in China
called South Korea don't worry you can
train with me January 25th chinese new
year new me
a lot of my Asian friends make fun of me
because I like to eat General Tso's
chicken like isn't that just a shitty
Americanized version of something
authentic Asian and I'm like yeah but so
my favorite movie is rush hour 3 it's uh
it's great being Asian you know I expect
racism from time to time like I was
walking across the street this guy comes
up to me he's like Tokyo
we took a yogi so as I do you're so
racist this guy's eyes look like this
let me speak your ching chong wang yeah
Oh pay raises and the post office is
right there a lot of people make fun of
us
Asians because we like to eat dogs which
I understand to be very shocking because
in America dogs are treated like family
members but in Asia we treat our family
members like family members this real
little tradition we have an animal we
just love our grandma unless she's a
baby girl forever I find I heard a date
as an Asian man you know every what
these Asian women are beautiful not
everyone things Asian matter beautiful
which doesn't even make any sense
because how do you think Asian women are
created crucial part of the sexy process
please sometimes scared me if you have
children together and shown are we very
beautiful then have we great engineers
in that support too I am single I've yet
to meet my soul mate
I'm beginning to think maybe it's her
polish she is get out more like a loser
I think I could be a better honest I am
a sapiosexual so I'm looking for a
girlfriend is not only very beautiful
but also intellectually stimulated by
the mental exercise of finding me
attractive a woman is into puzzles oh
yeah you're right that tonight my
friends are always like you to learn how
to talk to women maybe or maybe women
should learn how to listen to Hans whoo
I'm trying to hear about the Federal
Reserve it was like did you know that
because I can make a baby my vagina is
technically a 3d printer so actually
that's incorrect your womb is a 3d
printer China is the tray it only prints
one thing with lots of errors
my mother print and the whole time is
printing is complaining Vanessa said not
see any trays that night
I wonder women give birth I feel like as
Maggie gave birth would be like bro I've
been hearing so much protein and
creatine during my pregnancy this baby's
like 27 pounds right
about those games in the first trimester
[Laughter]
my girlfriend's like dude we're so lucky
we're not gay can you imagine if most of
the gender we were attracted to wasn't
attracted to us back I was like whoa
can't even imagine I understand what
people say it's Adam and Eve not Adam
and Steve because Adam and Eve were not
even a good couple bit ugly first of all
it disobeyed God and they eat our fruit
they weren't supposed to eat which is
kinda gay then and then they raised Cain
and Abel and Cain murdered Abel
well they taking parenting advice from
people raised a murderer don't like
three other people on earth they killed
a quarter of the world's your startup I
[Laughter]
don't believe a circumcision I think
that's a stupid stuff what's more likely
that we went through millions of years
of evolution and we ended up with a
reproductive organ that doesn't work
properly or the people of the Bible were
kind of weird about this
it says to prevent infection but I'll
wash my penis you have to lop off body
parts to make me dishwasher safe so I am
an atheist now because I'm not in
kindergarten and have an internet
connection I think it'd be stressful to
the world you like you've destroyed by
facts
[Laughter]
I grew up Christian as an Asian person
which is kind of weird because the
people who wrote the Bible didn't even
seem to know that Asia is existed you
can even drop us a lot in your book I am
a big supporter of Andrew yang right now
I'm part of the yang gang
I can't wait til we all live in a yang
stirs paradise hit the streets in 2020
go ahead yang banging I think if
everyone got $1,000 every month you guys
would be a lot more bearable to be
around there's some money is still
walking so close behind me on subway I
don't understand these CEOs really how
am I supposed to motivate my employees
if I can't turn them with this people
want people to work for my company I
have to have a company people want to
work for the private health care to
really do it what we wanted I mean I
think capitalism is great if you want to
do it just don't make everyone play a
stupid game I like for tonight I don't
make a grandma playing takeaway or a
house issue is
like how Americans will say communism
never works as if we didn't spend
billions of dollars in kill millions of
people to make sure it won't work over
the war in Vietnam and Panama Cuba
Uruguay South America in general we're
pretty anxious about it not working
communism ever works because remember
people control the means of production
the democratically like the leaders
mysteriously died the small rubber group
always finds an automatic weapons lock
debating themselves lemon stamping